[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN TABONE: That was good.
I got some woots and I got
all right, just like straight.
I'm glad that there's
still some energy
at the end of the second
day after the keynote.
My name is Ryan Tabone.
I am Director of Product
Management on G Suite.
Thank you all for
coming here today.
I wanted this to be a little
bit of a different session
than other sessions.
A lot of sessions will
go deep on one product
or go deep on
something technically.
This session is really
meant to piece everything
that you've been seeing together
over the last year, year
and a half, the
announcements we had today,
and where we're
going in the future
and give you a little bit of
the thought process behind all
of this, the data that we
use, and just a little peek
behind the curtain.
First though, I'm going
to go a little bit meta.
I am going to for the
next 30-ish minutes
try and get whatever is in my
head into all of your heads.
That's what a
presentation about, right?
The speaker is trying to
get the content that he
has into the audience's mind.
This notion of trying
to get what's in my head
into all of your
heads, it's part
of something we like to
call capturing and conveying
thought.
And really, it's what the
entire productivity market
is based on, trying
to get you to be
able to capture and convey
thought more effectively.
But yet, there's this
irony of the situation
because this is
productivity market, which
is trying to become
more efficient,
but there's no real
metric, no real number
that says, hey, you're
doing this more efficiently.
Actually by switching
to these tools,
you're actually making your
company more efficient.
We don't actually have that.
There are tools that
say, OK, this is
how you're spending your time.
In fact, there's also
negative metrics, right?
So I don't know if
you've heard this
before but a notification
can break you from your flow.
And it may take you 20,
30, or even 40 minutes
to get back into the state of
high throughput production.
Now, that's interesting,
but it doesn't really
help you justify an ROI
on productivity software
or a switch to certain
productivity software.
Now, this is where Google
has a unique vantage point.
We have some genuine
insights here
because we spend a lot of
time and resources on this.
How many of you are familiar
with the "New York Times"
study on Project Aristotle?
OK, well, the people
in the front row
are going to have to help
me inform everyone else.
I will give you a
high level here.
Google did a study starting
in 2012 where we actually
studied how our teams work.
And being a data
driven company, we
obsessed and analyzed
everything that our teams did.
And we learned a ton.
And we realized
that we actually had
to take a lot of these
processes to the enterprise.
And it was the justification for
us starting the Early Adopter
Program, which some of you are
probably familiar at this point
because we launch a lot
of our products that way.
It started about a year ago.
And the notion behind this
is that if we have use cases
that we're trying to
solve, how do we make sure
that we get them in
front of customers
and get the feedback in
order to actually craft
the future solutions?
And that's great from a
qualitative perspective.
But again, we're a
data driven company.
We also have the benefit of
being a Cloud-native suite
meaning that when we deploy
a solution to all of you,
we actually can see, hey, did
the behavior changes that we
intended actually happen.
We can actually look
at usage patterns
and look at how our products
are actually being used.
Now, something
interesting came out
when we actually looked at
this usage data, another tidbit
that we didn't quite expect.
And that is that
most people spend
their time not on the actual
ideas that you have, right?
We all have unique ideas.
That is our value.
But they don't spend most
of their time on that.
They spend most of their time
learning and manipulating
tools for rather mundane tasks.
Let's walk through
an example of this.
Scheduling a meeting,
I'm sure none of you
are familiar with
this process, right?
Never had to schedule a
meeting before in your life.
So I'm going to teach you about
how you schedule a meeting.
I got some smiles there.
Yes, this is a process we all
know and it's really painful.
What happens?
You ever try and
schedule a meeting
with I don't know 5, 10 people
across different sites, maybe
different time
zones, try and find
an available time that
works for everyone,
try and find a meeting room.
Good luck with that.
Then try and find the
documents that you
need for that discussion.
Maybe, it's the meeting
notes from last time.
It's the presentation
that you have.
This can take several
hours in some instances.
And then what happens when
the key people in the meeting
cancel?
You just got to go
through that again.
Now, this is just one
example of a mundane task.
There's tons in
our everyday life
that we probably
just don't even think
about, email management,
formatting documents, finding
files, expense reports.
It's not hard to
think about places
where it's not that you're
producing unique ideas.
You're just doing the same
tests on a different data set.
All right.
So let's make this real.
Going back to data again.
This is going to be an
audience participation
point so just yell out here.
When someone creates a
document, what percent of time
do you think most
people spend actually
capturing the idea
they have relative
to other processes
in that document?
AUDIENCE: 3%.
RYAN TABONE: 3%.
16?
I'm also part deaf.
So you're going to
have to project.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: 35?
RYAN TABONE: 35%.
Are we doing Price
is Right rules?
AUDIENCE: 0.
RYAN TABONE: 0.
AUDIENCE: $1.
RYAN TABONE: $1.
Yeah, I think we went
full Price is Right.
That wasn't what was
supposed to happen.
Well, I think 3% won because
it's actually closer to 5%.
The rest of it--
so 5% spent on your
actual ideation,
the thing that's valuable,
the whole thing that you're
trying to convey.
And the rest is spent on various
forms of research, formatting,
refinement.
And this is not just
unique to documents.
I'm sure that as I'm
talking about this,
you're starting to do
this analysis of yourself
where you're like
how much time am I
spending on my actual thought
versus just using tools?
It happens all the time.
The time that-- Oh,
should I go back?
I just saw a lot
of phones go down.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RYAN TABONE: All right.
I'm going to give you
five seconds because we're
on a clock here people.
No, I'm kidding.
It's fine.
So this time, this
time that people
spend on learning
and manipulating
tools for mundane
tasks, we call it
overhead because of
the obvious opportunity
loss or opportunity cost.
That's the word.
But what if we did a better job
of building tools, ones that
were cognizant of what
you needed when and maybe
were even cognizant
of who you work with
and your larger
organizational needs?
Well, then maybe, just maybe,
we could kill overhead.
All right.
Well, how do we do that?
This is where we turn
to machine learning
and artificial
intelligence, or ML and AI.
And I'm sure this is
a surprise, right?
This is the first time you're
hearing about these terms?
No?
Oh, you didn't hear
it all this morning?
How many of you
skipped the keynote?
You've heard a lot
about it already.
And you'll hear a lot about
it more within the industry.
Now, machine learning
for those of you who
are not familiar with
it at this point,
it may sound intimidating.
And the math is pretty
involved, but the concept's
pretty straightforward.
Machine learning algorithms
observe examples.
And then they make predictions.
Simple enough, right?
Let me give you an example
of how this has worked.
So Gmail, a long time ago in
a far, far away place, Gmail
started studying spam using
these machine learning
algorithms.
And they fed it
this algorithm spam
emails and non-spam emails.
And guess what
that algorithm did?
When an incoming
email would come in,
it could predict whether it
was a spam email or a non-spam.
Layer on many years, and
now we get to a point
where, hopefully, if
you're using Gmail,
I'm sure everyone is in
some form in this room,
you rarely, if ever, see spam.
But we're getting
to a point where
machine learning and
artificial intelligence
are making a lot more progress.
I'm sure you've seen
this in the news
that we are very proud
as a company of having
market leading machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
There's a lot of press about it.
You probably saw how we were
able to defeat the go champion.
Why does that matter?
It matters because it shows
that we're now making progress
fast enough at a point
that we didn't even
expect that we could start using
machine learning to actually
make an improvement
directly in our products
and help you and assist
you in your experience
as you're using it, not
just in the background
like in the case of spam.
And we're in a position
to actually use this more
than others in the
industry because we
are a Cloud-native platform.
So we have these tools
sitting on these data centers.
We have these products
We can actually integrate
them more rapidly,
make big bets because we don't
have any legacy in governments.
And then can again use
that data, the data
that I mentioned before to see
how we iterate on that cycle.
Now, and the proof as I
mentioned is in our products.
It's not just that
machine learning
has improved the magic of
Google Search, which it has.
It also transformed Google
Translate, transformed
translate, changed Google
Translate overnight.
Now, of course, there was a lot
of work that led to that point.
But all of the sudden,
overnight people
couldn't tell the difference
between what Translate had done
and what a human
translator had done.
That's pretty incredible.
And we're building this into
our enterprise flows as well.
Now, when we think
about how to build this
into our enterprise
flows, we have
to look at what flows exist.
And it turns out
that there's really
two types of flows, the
individual and the team.
And if you don't
solve for both, you
don't actually improve
efficiency in the enterprise.
You need to solve for both.
And they're related, but
they're very different problems.
Let's first look
at the individual
focused flows and see
some of the improvements
we've made there.
Smart reply, this feature
was launched in inbox.
And the idea was,
well, let's see
how people respond to a bunch
of emails again that observe
examples, make predictions.
And then we could start
making predictions
about incoming emails,
what you're likely to say.
And what's
interesting about this
again, because we want
to measure and see
how people respond to it, for
our power users, the ones who
use this day in,
day out, every day,
they have the ability to save up
to 14 minutes a day in typing.
That's crazy to me.
I still try and wrap
my head around that.
And Slides Explore.
How many of you have ever
had to make a presentation?
I envy the people who did
not raise their hands.
And how much time
did you spend just
pushing pixels around trying
to get things to format just
to look just right to get
your idea done correctly?
Well, you're not the only ones.
We're not all designers,
so it takes a lot of time.
And rather than talk
through this slide,
I'm actually going to go
ahead and jump to a demo,
if we can switch to
the demo machine.
Here you have a sample
deck with formatting.
It will show up.
We'll get there.
So how's everyone doing?
So we have this deck.
Let me close this out.
And you can see I
spent a lot of work
making a sample deck for you all
because it's all lorem ipsum.
And it's gone again.
OK, so we're just going
to have to like blink
really fast and
every fifth blink
you'll see what I'm about to do.
So I'm just going to
create a new slide here.
And I have a hypothesis
that weather affects--
am I spelling it wrong?
Affects, I got it.
OK, presentations.
So if this
presentation sucks, I'm
blaming it on it
being sunny out.
And I'm going to hit
Explore over here.
Now, I don't actually
have any data
for this, which if you
know me drives me insane.
And then I'm going to say--
I'm going to type in weather
map, which you see I've already
typed this in before.
And I'm going to
look for images.
And I'm just going to
pull an image over here
because that one looks pretty.
It's got a lot of colors.
And I'm going to type in
presentation and that one
looks.
OK, done, right?
How much time would you spend
now trying to format this?
So you got rid of
those ugly bars.
And you got it
laid out correctly.
And it would take a while.
I don't even know
what's going on
behind me, so just
pretend like it's working.
How's everyone doing?
So now, I'm just going
to hit Explore again.
Guess what?
I just have a bunch of layouts
that I can use instantly.
What did I do?
Absolutely nothing.
This one I actually
really like because not
only did it crop
and scale the images
and got rid of the
nastiness, it actually
also used the-- blank screen.
I'm just going to cut
all remaining demos.
I'm just going to start
telling horrible stand-up jokes
and maybe that's me.
Is it me?
Someone in the
back, magic person,
if you want to come forward
and fix my horribleness.
That's fine too.
What it actually did
here is it actually
formatted it to look
like the template
that I have for my company.
So now, I have custom colors.
It actually recolored
the images themselves,
cropped and zoom them,
and used the right fonts,
the right layouts.
So now, I look like a
professional designer
even though I did
absolutely nothing.
And that's the way
it should be, right?
You focus on your idea
not on the formatting.
Oh, forget it, just go
back to the presentation.
I'm not going there anymore.
You can do it.
Come on.
If we all click our
heels will it happen?
Presentation?
Maybe?
OK, so the actual
usage data here
showed us that people who use
this feature save about 50%
of the time in making slides.
It's crazy.
Really, I honestly
want the presentation.
I'm not kidding.
All right.
I'll go to another one.
I'm just going to talk to it.
Oh, we got the big
controller out.
Drive quick access, so we talked
a little bit about this today.
You ever have that
instance where
you're about to
go to this meeting
and you need that one file
with that piece of data
because you--
and you know you've
seen it before
and maybe even last
time at this meeting
you saw it and you want
to just pull it back.
And you just-- what
folder was it in?
It's horrible.
Well, drive quick access uses
a number of different signals,
like your calendar,
your email, what
you did around this last time--
I'm getting yelled
at from the screen.
It's amazing.
I'm going to try and do
this while talking to you.
This is like my best
magic trick ever.
Oh, wait, hold on a second.
I'm just going to
detach this screen
and hopefully that
will fix it for you.
We going to get back there?
So what drive quick access
does is it actually serves up
the files for you based on these
signals, being able to say,
hey, this is what you're
most likely to use.
I don't really know
what's going on.
I think I'm just now
going to describe
with interpretive dance
all the rest of my slides.
I don't know what that is.
Go for it.
Yeah, thank you, appreciate it.
OK, so drive quick access--
and what that did is
it actually also saved
people 50% of their time.
Now, we started
saying, OK, we're
throwing out these numbers,
seconds, 50% of time,
what does that actually mean?
I don't understand.
OK, so we try to make it real.
Let's say you take all of
these three features, just
these three features.
And you say someone becomes
a power user of these three
features and uses
them every day.
How much time does it
actually save them?
Well, we find that it actually
saves them two business--
or can save them up to two
business weeks per year,
just for those three features.
OK, here's another
question for you.
How many of you--
I'm just going to
here if it's possible.
How many of you are
spreadsheet ninjas?
That's my interpretive
dance again.
All right.
That's probably about right.
Less than 30% of
enterprise users
actually feel comfortable
manipulating formulas
in a spreadsheet.
And yet, spreadsheets
are the most--
OK, we're here.
This wasn't-- OK, sure.
Spreadsheets are the most relied
upon source of data or source
of data in an enterprise.
So now, how do you rectify
those two statements, right?
Most people don't know how
to manipulate spreadsheets,
but everyone uses them
for their source of data.
Well, obviously,
what's happening
is that a lot of this
load is being shifted
to a small number of people.
So we had this goal to
democratize this analysis
so that everyone can use it.
And we called that Explore.
So I'm going to--
now, that I'm in here, I'm
just going to show you this.
So here's a wall of data that
we commonly call a spreadsheet.
And I'm going to
click on Explore.
And the resolution's going to
be a little bit funky here.
But I think you get the point,
which is I didn't do anything.
I don't even know how
to use this spreadsheet.
But automatically, I'm starting
to get something over here
on the side.
Here's some analysis.
Let me go into
that a little bit.
OK, I have a chart.
It's showing me the link of
cost of goods and profit.
And there's actually this
little text insight here,
for every increase in $100
profit, cost of goods increases
by $113.
So it costs me more and more to
make the same amount of profit.
That's pretty interesting.
But that means someone
could have just sent me
this spreadsheet and I could
just walk into a board meeting
and just say, hey,
did you know this?
I didn't do one set of analysis.
But what's
interesting about this
is that we're not trying
to teach you formulas
anymore, right?
Instead, the spreadsheet
app is trying
to teach you about your data.
And that's the goal.
So I could make this easy.
And I could just drop
that chart in if I want.
Now, that's all well and
good, but really when
people open up spreadsheets
they're looking generally
to answer a question.
So in this case, the title
of this, which I think
is in the top left, Holiday
Week Sales or Holiday Sales.
Wrong, laptop.
So let's say I wanted
to understand more
about my holiday sales.
In fact, I wanted to
just ask the question
in this little section
here called Answers
where I will say, what
were the top selling
items on Black Friday?
And I got a table back.
And it said the answer,
the top 30 items
during 25th of November 2016
and there's a list with a count.
Oh, and there's also--
this is my favorite part.
And there's also
a formula that I
would have to write if I
wanted to do it myself.
I consider myself
a semi spreadsheet
ninja, maybe like a white
belt. And I can't do that.
So, wow, you just got me what
I intended without actually
having to do any work.
I just asked the question
and you got an answer back.
I want to pause on
this for a second.
We did that so quick that people
are like, eh, that's cool.
What actually
happened during this
is that I typed
in this question.
We used our market leading,
natural language processing
to break down that
question and say,
OK, top selling items
plural and Black Friday.
OK, what does Black Friday mean?
OK, it is a term that
corresponds to a date.
And what date do
we actually mean?
And, oh, by the way, that
date changes every year.
If I change that to 2015,
it would know as well.
And then it takes those pieces.
And then it maps them against
the data, creates this formula,
and generates this
answer, not bad.
This is what happens
when you have market
leading machine intelligence.
And what we saved here is
instead of someone sending
a spreadsheet to an analyst
with a list of questions
and saying, hey, can you
help me out with this?
And then going through
a few iterations
as he prioritizes that
work among the 10,000
other spreadsheets that he got.
And you go through a few cycles.
You may get back an
answer at the end of that,
but you definitely
spent a lot of payroll.
In this case, you make
analysis again available
instantly and for all.
OK, can we maybe go back
to the presentation again?
Yes.
Hey, look this is
that quick access
thing I was talking about.
And then there's Sheets Explore.
Wow, we're just-- we're
plowing through here.
This is great.
So having this market leading
machine intelligence is what--
or machine learning and
artificial intelligence
is what allows us to
ship these features.
And this is also the
reason why answers
in Sheets Explore and smart
reply are unique in the market.
They haven't been
able to be duplicated.
OK, I mentioned before that
in order for an enterprise
to be efficient you have
to be able to solve,
not only for the individual,
but for the team.
And the team really is a
completely different problem.
Let's do a thought experiment.
OK, think about how
you work at home.
How often is your work
shared with others?
AUDIENCE: Never.
RYAN TABONE: Never.
That was the answer
I was going for,
except some people will
share it with their spouse.
Around this time of year, the
common answer is accountant.
Other than that, yeah,
it's pretty much solo work.
OK, now think about
how you work at work.
How much of your success is
dependent on your work alone?
Any one?
AUDIENCE: Very little.
RYAN TABONE: Very little.
I appreciate that.
You kind of gave me a lob there.
A lot of people say they realize
that really none of it is all--
even if you--
I talked to a
reporter yesterday.
And I was like, well, do you--
I mean your name's on it.
This is you, right?
This is just-- She's
like, no, I can't do this
without a whole team of people.
Everyone I've ever
talked to says
they can't be successful
without working with a team.
And these teams are a mix of
wonderful, hopefully wonderful,
people with unique
traits and skills.
And that's why you're paired
together with them because you
each have different skills
that you can work together
to accomplish your task.
But what does that
actually look like when
you're working with these
other folks in this team?
Does that look somewhat right?
I'm sure most of you
probably haven't mapped out
how your teams work
together, but probably this
resonates a little bit with you.
Meetings, action
items, more meetings,
balancing other projects,
collaborating, scheduling out--
oh I have to make sure that
I get this done before I
get something else done.
It's not straightforward.
Now, you see why the team
problem is a different problem.
Now, let me add overhead to
each one of these pieces, right?
Before, we talked about
meetings and adding overhead
of just scheduling one meeting.
How about the meeting,
the milestone meeting,
the sub meetings in between,
and then within that everyone's
going to have their
different sets of tools
to do their different
tracks as well
as be able to
prioritize their time
within those different tracks.
And also I, need to
track the action items
between these different things.
And, oh, where did I store
those assets because so and so--
it gets to be a mess.
In fact, it gets so bad teams
break because of this, right?
I'm waiting on someone
to get my job done.
They haven't prioritized
the thing accordingly.
We haven't had a
discussion about it
because they can't find
time in their calendar.
I'm going to move on
to something else.
And then what happens?
Well, now a project that
could've taken a day
is going to take two
weeks because I'm sorry,
I'm working on something else.
I see some heads nodding.
I'm sure none of you can
relate to this at all.
All right.
Well, the goal here is to not
only remove that overhead,
but just to really
understand how people
work together, to really
understand their priorities,
to start laying out
their future for them,
to make all of
those steps simpler,
and fit in with each
other so that you work
towards a common
goal, and that we
help you achieve that common
goal on a common timeline.
This allows you to focus on
your task as a team, as a unit,
as opposed to the overhead of
the process of each individual
within the unit.
And when you do that,
it makes an impact
not just on you
as an individual,
but on your entire team and
your entire organization.
And this is why we
relaunched Google Cloud and G
Suite a few months ago.
It's because we're focusing on
how enterprises work together
in teams.
Now, this may seem
like, oh, well,
haven't we been solving this
problem for a really long time?
No.
It's actually a relatively
new concept for the market.
And, yeah, there are a
few point solutions here,
but really to solve this, you
need a suite working together.
Because as you see,
there are many different
flows where everyone's using
different sets of tools.
If they aren't all cognizant
of the common goal,
you're still going to
have those overhead.
And you're still going
to break the process.
So what are we doing
within G Suite?
Well, it started
with the docs editors
and real-time collaboration.
That may have shifted the entire
industry towards that model
because they realize it helped
teams work closer together.
But we wanted to take
it to the next level.
And we made a few
announcements today.
For those of you who
were at the keynote,
consider this somewhat
of a refresher.
Jamboard, now this
is the ability
to actually look at a team space
and combine virtual with real.
I can be in one room, you
can be in another room,
and what generally happens is
instead of working together
on a white board, the
people in one room
work together on a white board
and then we go, trust us,
it's working.
Trust us, we got this going.
I'm going to take a
picture and send it to you.
Sure, that's going to happen.
Or, they write do not
erase on it, right?
So that when the person
does-- is in the same room,
they can see it because
that always works.
But instead, now, I can
actually join two virtual rooms
into one real room where we
can all work together and then
resume this work later on.
And we all get copies of it.
Again, rethinking how
teams work together.
But we also went a step further
to lay foundational ground.
Now, this is actually
pretty important
because this sets a journey
for us that goes on a ways.
When teams work together they
really need two core pieces.
One is a source of
truth and another
is a way to communicate
about that source of truth
in order to work towards a goal.
Make sense?
Straightforward.
This is actually like the
complete background for a lot
of our launches today.
It was that thought process.
OK, so let's go
to the first one.
Source of truth, team drives.
The idea behind this is I don't
want to think about storage.
I have a team.
I want to know
where my assets are.
Who has ownership?
Wait, do you see that file?
I don't see that file.
Is that there?
No, all of that gone.
I don't want to worry
about permissions.
It should just work.
I should be able to say
I'm going to Team Foo
and all of my stuff
for Team Foo is there.
In addition, because
we want to make
teams as efficient
as individuals,
again, we're bringing
quick access,
which is that thing I
showed you before that has
50% savings to teams as well.
OK, now you have
your source of truth,
you want to communicate
about your source of truth.
When we actually
talked to customers,
we realized-- and to
teams, we realized
that there's two forms
of communication that
happen on a source of truth.
For those of you who
saw the announcements,
you know what's coming,
but here's the rationale
of how we got there.
One is a continuous,
asynchronous form
of communication where constant
progress can be made, right?
Let's say I go to a meeting.
And Bob and Sue on my team
still are discussing the problem
at hand, pulling
relevant content
from that source of truth.
They need to be able
to have that discussion
and move it forward.
Now, if that happens in
one-off conversations,
I'm not going actually know.
And I'm going to hope
someone tells me.
You actually need a
way to capture what's
going on and being able to
reference back those materials
as well as the
decisions being made.
And that was the reason why
we launched Hangouts Chat
together.
This is a way to make
teams work together
and have one place where
they can coexist and make
constant decisions
and discussions.
OK, so now you have-- and
also be able to easily locate
this content.
So you see at the top
a really quick way
to be able to search
and find that content.
The second form of
communication is discreet
face-to-face high bandwidth.
I need to get five
people in the room.
Text just isn't cutting it.
We got somebody in Taiwan.
We got somebody in Europe.
I need to get them
altogether right now.
And it has to be simple,
again, because we want
to go and kill that overhead.
Because if it takes
10 minutes to set up
a meeting for 5 people, you just
wasted 50 minutes not just 10
for yourself.
And that's why we
launched Hangouts Meet.
And the idea is two
clicks and you're in,
dial ins for those who
can't make it on the VC,
and best in class
video and audio.
All right.
Now, that we have those pieces,
we're going to build on them.
We're going to layer in
things like workflow,
being able to predict
what you need when,
routing content,
prioritizing and tracking
tasks, automatically
scheduling blocks of time.
For those of you who saw
the demo today with At Meet,
that exactly what
happened, right?
That idea of calendaring
now just went away.
I was able to take
five people in a room
and just create an
instant meeting for us.
We can kill this overhead
through these tools.
And this is the vision to
take world class intelligence
and bake it into a suite
of tools that work together
because that's the
only way that we can
get teams to actually
work efficiently
on their different tasks.
All right.
Quick wrap up.
Today, we showed
productivity tools actually
cost more time in
overhead than actually
helping you complete a task.
We can address those
today for individuals
using machine learning.
And for teams, combining machine
learning with a suite of tools
is the only way that
we will actually
be able to address their needs.
And we laid the foundational
pieces with team drives, chat,
and meet.
Also, interpretive
dance doesn't work
for telling a presentation.
But this is the start
of a longer journey.
And I encourage you that part
of the reason why I'm here
is hopefully you see
where we're headed.
And it makes you want to take
your teams onto these products
now so that as we iterate and
build on top of this stack,
your team gets the benefit
without having to teach them
something new because we'll
be doing the work for them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]